(lighthearted piano music)
- Oh, last night, you know?
- Yeah, right.
- I'm Tyler.
- Richard.
- Richard, nice to meet you, man.
- Nice to meet you.
- Yeah, you new to this bar?
- Yeah, it's my first
time here, it's nice.
- Awesome, that's great.
I hate to be this guy, but,
I'm gonna have to ask
you to take your hat off.
(laughter)
- Right, okay, I get it,
cause you're wearing a hat.
- Well, it's just like,
only fedora per bar or party, you know?
- Wow, you're being serious.
- If a king was to throw
some kinda royal masquerade,
and he showed up wearing a crown,
and then a random guy off
the street just showed up to
the party too, also wearing a crown,
people would be confused.
- Are you calling yourself a king?!
- Okay, look, fedora the explorer,
I just don't wanna have to like,
box you up into a box
and FedEx you outta here.
- Cause of fedora.
- [Tyler] Fedora.
- [Richard] I get it, okay.
- [Tyler] FedEx.
- [Richard] Who's judging us, man?
No one cares!
- [Tyler] Get outta here, K-Fed.
- Listen, I'm not taking off
this hat cause, you know what?
It looks dope on me, alright?
And your hat looks dope on you, okay?
So we can both wear hats
and look dope together!
- I'm gonna give you until
the count of three, man.
To either get the H out or take the H off.
- You know what, I'll take it off!
I'll take it off!
Because, you know what?
You're right!
I wanna be more original than you.
- You know what, know what,
I'm gonna take the higher ground,
and I'm gonna take the fedora off.
- Oh, really?!
Now you're gonna take your fedora off?
- Yeah, welcome to my bar, man.
Welcome to my bar.
- Your bar.
- Hey, this guy's a new fedora guy,
cause I'm not wearing a fedora anymore.
- No, I'm taking it off, too.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
- Come on, man, come on.